je pense qu'aujourd'hui on nous le
discours sur la défense de la transition
écologique juste qu'on a un président
qui s'expriment beaucoup sur le sujet
mais qui en décalage total avec les
décisions politiques qu'il prend au plan
au plan national
moi je suis ramassé interpellé par cette
démarche de deux jeunes qui mettent en
accusation la france pour ne pas
respecter ses engagements climatiques
donc on aura l'occasion sûrement de
d'évoquer voilà cette forme de paradoxe
entre les engagements officiels la
défense de la coop 21 de ses conclusions
et sur le terrain manifestement des
décisions qui n'ont pas dans le même
sens donc paradoxe cynisme abandonné les
choix politiques devront être expliquées
aux français est-ce que selon vous greta
tanberg elle en fait trop en attendant
cette action justice a envers la france
n'est pas la chine aux états unis par
exemple
cette jeune femme devient une icône
chacun l'a bien compris il faut la
respecter
parce que je crois qu'elle est
profondément sincère bien évidemment
lancé les accusations doit aussi aboutir
à mandela des propositions on peut
s'opposer mais il faut savoir aussi
proposés mais elle secoue le cocotier
permettez moi de l'expression il faut la
respecter
en tant que tel et moi j'ai vu sa
déclaration hier devant l'onu et j'ai
senti une femme engagée une femme
sincère
une femme sûrement qui n'a pas tous les
codes mais finalement qui nous dérangent
et sur la transition écologique il faut
savoir être dérangés pour pouvoir encore
mieux agir demain